the fear that comes out of whatever is
left of the core Community is you guys
don't have a right to go direct to
Consumer you don't have a right to talk
about the field that belongs to a tiny
number of people who do this morning
noon and night who are all possessed of
common beliefs there have to be some
standards on the other hand the the core
group that's been trying to gate this
has failed we have uh
graciously uh been joined with two of
the most uh prominent and uh two of my
real heroes in this field that are
Maverick mathematicians who are uh
self-made mathematicians in a way and I
want to talk about how they view the
current Spirit of the times the
Zeitgeist as we say in terms of theories
of everything that are percolating
around in the uh in the in the
atmosphere and to begin with I'll ask my
guest uh Eric to introduce yourself and
uh say a little bit about where people
can find you we'll do that right up
front and then uh uh we'll get started
with our discussion topics we're gonna
have a nice clean fight we're going
toe-to-toe no there's not gonna be any
fight it's going to be uh very uh very
respectful so thank you both for joining
Eric can you introduce yourself and I'll
buy me some time to tweet out this link
check my feed Eric Weinstein I'm a
managing director at teal capital I come
from a mathematics background uh so I'm
not a physicist and I have an Eclectic
uh podcast called the portal which
uh I hope to have in fact I've got
agreements from both of these gentlemen
to uh to be my guests on the portal so
I'm really looking forward to that and
happy to help blow up into the
impossible Brian you're doing a
fantastic job I love it and it's all
thanks to to you guys you guys were
actually uh my first guest in what I
call the pandemic podcast series which
uh began back in in April actually late
March with Stephen uh was the first of
the two of you to come on the podcast
and really kicked off this whole idea a
uh of getting some of the world's most
Brilliant Minds to engage around this
topic of understanding the fundamental
nature of the universe and at that time
uh because of the pandemic perhaps
Stephen's schedule uh was amenable to
coming on my podcast so we chatted for a
mere three hours or so and uh he's as I
said gracious enough to come back
Stephen where are you joining us from
today I'm in Concord
Massachusetts and uh do I introduce
myself I'm St wol from my do science and
technology and things I built some
technology things lots of people use I
built some science lots of people use
and uh about 30 years ago well I I used
to be a particle physicist long ago I
did that when I was a kid and um then uh
I got interested in computation and have
kind of alternated between doing basic
science and doing technology and I've
now done about five cycles of that
and um I think it's a very interesting
process actually alternating between
basic science and and Technology because
they kind of build on each other and
it's sort of a a progressively spiral
upward so to speak yeah but um the big
surprise for me was um about bit more
than a year ago now a bunch of things
that I've been thinking about about um
how to make a fundamental Theory of
physics um actually thought I think I
actually have some way forward and
couple of young physicists were really
enthusiastic about working with me on it
and so we're like okay let's try and
really do something and the huge
surprise is that it's worked and which I
didn't expect yeah I mean it's it's um
you know we've been we're at a hundred
years roughly for you know General
altivity and quantum mechanics which are
the two sort of big uh achievements of
20th century physics and uh you know
they've taken us a great distance but um
uh you know I had a bunch of ideas that
have been sort of based on things that
came out of the whole computational
thinking that I've done and anyway the
the big surprise it's worked and not
only did it seem to have worked when I
last talked to you it's been going
absolutely spectacularly since then and
um it's it's really it's really it's
kind of like embarrassing because there
a lot of things I should have been able
to figure out 20 30 years ago which are
now becoming obvious and I think one of
the other things to say is that one of
the surprises to me is that I had
thought we were building this kind of
prong in the direction of kind of
computation that would be really
different from the mathematical physics
and so on that people have done before
turns out we basically built a sort of a
low-level machine code for how things
work but it turns out an awful lot of
the formalisms that people have worked
on in mathematical physics the last 50
years or so they actually fit
beautifully into the kinds of things
that we're doing and they seem to kind
of illuminate what we we've done and
hopefully what we've done illuminates
what they're doing and I I actually my
favorite analogy in recent times for
this is what happened in early days of
computation Theory with uh things like
touring machines which was that people
had come up with you know models of
computation combinators Lambda calculus
General cursive functions things like
this but it wasn't clear how they fit
together and they all seemed rather
abstract and people couldn't kind of
tether them and then touring machines
came along and you know in the usual way
that Science History is done we could
say immediately everybody understood but
actually it took let's see how long 40
years 50 years so immediately it was
actually 40 or 50 years but but people
understood from from that kind of more
concrete tethering of these ideas about
computation how all these different
things fit together so that's been
that's been I mean it's both both
scientifically interesting to me and I
think also sociologically interesting
because often you know you come in with
the the big new Theory so to speak and
it's like uh you're kind of gunning down
everything else but that's not what's
happening here I mean what's happening
here is that we've got something which
is sort of orthogonal to what other
people have thought about it's kind of a
low-level you know low-level machine
code and we can kind of uh you know see
how things fit together at a high level
that's your elevator pitch that goes to
the space elevator St docking station uh
thank you Stephen and and both of you
guys are notable as people are pointing
out in the chat which I'm monitoring uh
so behave in there uh I am uh seeing a
lot of you know questions from younger
people and I think the two of you in
particular have an ability that other
scientists uh have not yet really U been
able to achieve which is to engage young
people and Stephen you just talked about
engagement by these young physics
students that you and I spoke about in
our first conversation back in uh in
April and with Eric people are you know
engaged on on Discord on on on comments
and and people all over the Internet are
really engaged with it what do you think
it does you know this this podcast the
in impossible podcast I like to Fashion
myself as you know someday I'll be the
Joe Rogan of of physics there's already
one Joe Rogan but I'd like to know what
is it about these theories of everything
that really engages young people and
what I want to do is kind of trans it's
fascinating that you have the sort of
bucket theories of everything I don't I
don't kind of view it as a bucket like
that for me you know I I I spent my life
basically developing computation and you
know the fact that I happen to have
discovered that that relates to kind of
fundamental Theory of physics is kind of
a a singular event as far as I'm
concerned it's it's a it's a the the
kind of the bucket of theories of
everything is is is not a bucket I
particularly identify right like an
agree with St Stephen there can only be
one what I said
today one of the surprising things that
we've discovered is that really isn't
true there can be many ways of
approaching that theory yes but but the
thing that's interesting is
that you know you could say there's only
fair enough I mean depends what you mean
by only one that's an interesting kind
of ontological epistemological question
but I mean it's like you know you could
say about computation there could only
be one theory of computation and its
touring machines or and its General
recursive functions the thing that's
surprising about physics that has become
increasingly clear is that the this kind
of um there's this notion of you know
what are the possible what are the
underlying rules and then how do we
observe those underlying rules and it's
becoming clear that you can basically
the only thing that is absolutely rigid
is the underlying rules are
computational and not hyper
computational that is once you say that
the underlying rules are purely
computational it then follows it seems
that the things we observe from 20th
century physics are inevitable
consequences of that and a few other uh
kind of unspecific assumptions the hard
thing to explain and actually we're just
I think okay so here's a here's a
remarkable connection that's just been
becoming clear so we have this notion of
you know you have some underlying rules
you follow these rules you you know
reproduce How the Universe works but on
the other side of that we are observing
how these rules are working and
interpreting them to say this is how the
universe works the thing that is
surprising is that one can I mean in the
in the language of our kind of theory
there's this thing called the Ral
multi-way system which is this kind of
this branching system that's that runs
sort of all possible rules I mean this
is we're now jumping into the most
abstract most most complicated but I
just want to say one thing about it
which is kind of kind of interesting
which is it's turning out that this
incredibly abstract thing that we have
this Ral multi-way system appears to be
the same as this thing called The
Infinity groupoid which was developed by
growth and deque in when it was it the
70s I guess 1970s which is kind of a a a
pinnacle of abstraction of category
Theory and other areas of mathematics
and what is really quite remarkable to
me is that it seems like this thing
that's coming out of of our Theory kind
of maps into this incredibly abstract
mathematical thing and the the
observations that we have of the
universe correspond to a particular in
mathematical terms kind of vibration of
this Infinity groupoid thing and that
basically what we're our our way of of
interpreting the universe is kind of a
slice of that uh of that mathematical
object and so it's it's it's the
statement there's only one theory in a
sense all these theories are equivalent
but the you know the question is how how
we are observing them I was making a pop
culture reference um the intellectual
Spirit of it is that you can have a
summit and there many faces that could
be used as as uh assaults on that Summit
in the end however we Traverse you know
Einstein for example came up with his uh
divergence-free equations after some
some rumbling around in differential
geometry Hilbert went um you know
immediately to a lan description they
were describing something in common so I
didn't mean to suggest that there was uh
a single description but there can
really only be one underlying Theory and
we all of us who are and I was trying to
agree with you Stephen that the most
probable number for for wrong guests on
this live stream is two but in all
probability if it is not two then one of
us is wrong it strikes me that you have
gained confidence that what you are
doing is actually not only capable of
producing a fundamental final Theory and
we can talk about what the right
language is I'm not wedded to any
particular description if you have if
you have an objection but it sounds to
me like you are increasingly convinced
that um week by week this is really the
most
promising uh assault on on our
foundations yeah first of all if I'm
wrong I hope that you or Garrett leasy
or one of these other crazy people uh
turns out to be right would be would be
a pleasure to lose to you sir the thing
to understand is the kind of system that
we've built it is very likely that you
know I don't don't understand what
you've done but but you know I know a
little bit of the mathematical
background you know the whole for for
example understanding local gauge
variants and understanding how fiber
bundles work in our systems as a student
actually at our recent summer school
mathematical physicist who managed to
make great progress on that and it's
actually very clever and much simpler
than I expected the way that essentially
sort of fiber bundle type structures and
local gauge inv variants arise in our
theories now what you do with with it
once it's Arisen from this kind of
low-level machine code that's you know
often running with much more traditional
mathematical physics and I don't think
that there's a you know it's not an
incompatible thing to say oh there's
some complicated structure to do with
you know high-dimensional systems and
fiber bundles and so on that that
doesn't that's not like there's no
there's no divide yet let's try to State
how you and I uh could both be fit into
the discussion that Brian is trying to
conduct
I definitely agree that uh you know
consilience is nice and and it's
wonderful to have consonant uh what the
viewers want as argumentation no I'm
just kidding I I don't care about that
but what I do think she get Sabina back
on exactly I think what would be really
a great outcome of this discussion would
be kind of the joining of your two
different different approaches I don't
know about Eric's stuff so I can't
really comment on that the people out in
that are watching that have as you just
said fiber bundles hop vibration uh
gauge inv variant but way of having sort
of a Rosetta Stone if there are people
out there I'm not asking or tasking you
guys God forbid with homework but people
in the respective uh domain experts in
both of your two categories I think that
would be an interesting kind of project
to see can these be reconciled because
so maybe I should explain what we're
doing okay because there's a fairly
large effort at this point what's been
happening you talk about engaging young
people you know what I've been trying to
figure out how to do this because
there's been a lot of enthusiasm for our
project a lot of people interested a lot
of people say I want to contribute to
this project okay so right now we have
we're just about to kind of roll out I
think we have 30 research Affiliates and
Junior research Affiliates who are
mostly people who came to the summer
school that we just spent a month having
um and they're people who are sort of In
Motion sort of doing research along the
lines of this project and you know
producing papers and so on and you know
one of the important objectives there
there's several important objectives but
one of them them is making these Bridges
to other kind of mathematical physics
approaches another thing is just being
able to check off the list there are you
know these effects known in quantum
mechanics there are these features of
General activity for example can we go
down the list and say okay you know we
have destructive interference we have
spin statistics connections we have this
we have that the thing that's just
absolutely amazing is every time I think
one of these is going to be really hard
it turns turn out to be much easier than
I think and that's been a big surprise
to me I mean I've been my expectations
keep on being kind of uh uh exceeded and
I think that the I mean the other
question is for example for something
like generality which I I know you know
you have a lovely Cosmic microwave
background globe in the uh back there
it's um right right up there it's very
cool yeah it's a weird that it's kind of
the the inversion of the sky so to speak
God's eye view right yeah right you know
so for for example there's the you know
we have a sort of mathematical proof
that in some limit we can reproduce
General rity but the question is can you
actualize that and so here's an
interesting example of how sort of you
know a direction we're going in which is
an interesting sort of way to validate
theories is the following thing so when
people normally study gravitation Theory
they say oh we've got Einstein's
equations from 1915 they work great but
if we actually want to find out how two
black holes merge we don't get to kind
of work out you know with Mathematica or
something the exact you know result for
you know how this ble merger will work
we have to make numerical approximations
to the Einstein equations so of break
them down into something discrete solve
them on our computer see what the
implications for for this process are
but that that kind of break down the the
Einstein equations into something
discret that can be solved on a computer
there's an alternative way to think
about that which is start from our
Theory which is born as something that
you can run on a computer and then go up
from there to get to something which can
reproduce What happens in black holes
and so on and so you know this is the
kind of thing I happen to do this years
ago with fluid dynamics where you can
start with these very simple in that
case cellular automatan models of fluid
dynamics and build up from those to
actually reproduce fluid phenomena but
anyway so the the thing is what I might
call proof by compilation so to speak
which is you're going from the kind of
low-level structure of the model
to actually do computations that can
then be compared with with black hole
Dynamics even though you sort of know it
has to work because you have a
mathematical proof that the two things
are equivalent but it's very satisfying
to see it actually work it hasn't we
haven't you know done that yet but we're
in the process of doing it and more
interestingly actually in Quantum field
Theory where numerical methods have been
much harder to apply it looks like we
have a pretty good way to do sort of
numerical Quantum field theory in a
different way than it's been done before
when you say it's easy what by what
metric or what uh what measure function
are you defining that easy in terms of
you know just easy for a brilliant you
know grandmas of of physics to unravel
or easy in terms of computational
efficiency in some sense no I mean for
example one of the things is do we have
to know how electrons work to be able to
or do we have to know what photons in
detail are before we can reproduce
effects in quantum mechanics the answer
is a lot of these phenomena seem to be
more generic than I expected and more
amable to being kind of explained
without having that whole Tower of of of
features built so that's the that that's
that's that's the main thing I mean by
by easier I think in terms of the the
technical difficulty and the
mathematical depth of what's going on
we're doing what physicists often do
which is we're skating over many of the
mathematical difficulties I mean in in
you know in some of these derivations
there are like 12 different limits that
have to be taken of you know this thing
is small compared to the size of the
universe but large compared to this but
small compared to the curvature of that
but large compared to this and so on and
you know each one of those limits is a
significant amount of mathematical work
to validate and so on and you know this
is the typical thing that's been done by
Feist Through the Ages I'm afraid that
just skate right over those things now
we have a big Advantage which is we can
do computer experiments so we kind of
know it's going to work I mean we know
we're not going to be too far off
because we can actually check a bunch of
these things in actual experiments
although the experiments we do you know
if the universe has 10 to the 400 you
know atoms of space in it we certainly
don't have that many in our computer so
we we're doing very small versions of
this you know I want to say that I think
it might be interesting for us to talk a
little bit about kind of the more sort
of societal and structural aspects
rather than getting too deep into the
into the wait a minute I was looking to
get I wanted to get into the into the
damn weeds go go for it okay we will we
will but small small amount of weed
weed whacking and then then we can talk
about um the bigger picture of Science
and the world and so on which I think I
think we probably both have things to
say about I think that Segways nicely
into a question that I brought up uh
with with both of you separately and and
then earlier today and that's that's
kind of the structure of the way that
scientific uh revolutions take place and
it's become a Trope you know nowadays to
say well there's a paradigm shift which
is brought upon by some new idea radical
usually some lone genius like you guys
uh working almost in solitude I'm just
teasing but you're just G to get us into
trouble with Reddit that's all you're
doing you're just baiting Reddit well
hopefully Dr Reddit is not watching yet
I guarantee she is what do you think
about this notion of Paradigm shifts do
you think it's really the way that
science takes place or or is it just
sort of a retro retrospective
retrodiction historical Narrative of
what has taken place that is just
convenient as a hack for the human mind
to say okay in retrospect the Paradigm
shifted with g ao's observation of the
Jovian satellites what do you Eric think
about this notion of cian Paradigm
shifting you have to have lived through
stasis and stagnation and through
Revolution and
boom and even if the boom isn't the
largest boom on record like you know the
gold rush or something in science I
lived through one or two revolutions um
one of which was a Rosetta Stone between
differential
geometry and Quantum field Theory at
least the the structure underneath
Quantum field theory that was figured
out in the mid1 1970s it doesn't have a
historical like you can't go to a a
biopic about it which is weird but um
your uh your friend Jim Simons Brian and
Cen Yang arguably maybe the greatest of
living physicists figured this out over
lunch and that Revolution is going on to
this day called the wooy Yang dictionary
there was another one having to do with
the discovery that Quantum field theory
was a mathem atically natural structure
not just a grab bag of techniques and
that it would have been discovered as an
enhancement of something in algebraic
topology since uh Dr Wolfram brings up
Alexander grth and deque in algebraic
topology we have a theory called bordism
which is an extraordinary chology Theory
and Quantum field Theory would be
discovered in enhancing bordism Theory
as Ed Whitten Michael latia and Graham
seagull and others taught us in the
1980s having seen Evolutions yes there
are things that you can tell people
where they they they're never the same
again they they they come to understand
you know as I as I've said before there
should be a tattoo on all of our seeum
if you can read this you're too close
when you pull your head out you can
better understand the world uh After the
Revolution and the what Dr Wolfram is
discussing uh is that we've had a small
number of complete Revolutions in our
thinking and many more minor
elaborations in our thinking there was
one around scale which might be called
the first and second renormalization
revolutions uh originally a fan and and
schwinger but then Ken Wilson really uh
was probably the big name in that area
having been through a few of these
revolutions having been close enough to
study them uh and also in a few
different fields like biology with uh
you know crisper C9 or optogenetics or
something like this yeah no these things
are real and they change everything and
you know my resistance to Steven's
Theory uh will one day turn into you
know my saying oh my God I can't believe
I I didn't understand what you were
saying it was too new to use fineman's
fa famous quote from when he tried to
introduce his path integral or P some
over history's approach he said my
machines came from too far away because
he was derided and you see a lot of
people we were Jing before about Reddit
just to close this out a lot of people
are trying to figure out what the hell
is going on in these live streams and
why does one person get get to be in
them and who's a crank and who isn't
they're trying to use some sort of
indicaa which is does that person sound
like they're wild eyye does that person
sound sober and it's a really odd moment
because on the one hand everybody sounds
crazy and some of the crazy people sound
among the most same and I think Dr Wolf
for for example despite the fact that I
think he's wrong I think that he is one
of the sanest voices out here one of the
most interesting for sure and part of
the problem is the mainstream of the
community sounds mad as a Hatter to me
uh Dr wol sounds much more reasonable so
let's comment on on Paradigm shifts and
so on I've been fortunate to live
through some myself even probably
responsible for some you know the main
process that seems to happen is a
methodological Advance is made that
opens up some new area there's a bunch
of lwh hanging fruit to be picked in
that area lots of exciting stuff happens
for 5 years 10 years maybe a little bit
longer that area of science gets big it
gets quite institutionalized it slows
down there's 50 or 100 Years of sort of
stasis and then maybe there's some
methodological advance and it and it
opens up again and typically in terms of
of sort of the the conceptualization of
these methodological advances it's
usually a long process for the people
involved in them and it's usually you
know you you have to sort of think about
things in the right way and then maybe
there's some moment when you realize yes
I can actually see how this works now
for example in in my current activities
in physics you know one of the
embarrassments of that is that the
fundamental model which is based on you
can think of it as based on rewritings
of hypergraphs or or a very minimalist
uh very sort of abstract thing about
Transformations for relations between
elements okay and that idea you can also
think of as transformation rules for
symbolic Expressions well the idea of
transformation rules for symbolic
Expressions is what I've been using
technologically in building comp
computational languages for 40 years and
it is super embarrassing in a sense that
the core idea which seems to have
unlocked what we're doing now in physics
is actually something I've been working
on for 40 years but I didn't see that
connection I mean what what's happened
is that normally in using symbolic
expressions and transformation rules for
symbolic expressions in computational
languages those symbolic Expressions
actually immediately mean something they
mean you know adding things together
they mean uh I don't know some other
some other identifiable kind of
operation whereas in the way we're using
them in physics it's just the
infrastructure they mean nothing they
get meaning because the things in them
turn into the things like the atoms of
space and so on but to begin with they
mean nothing so for me that's sort of an
interesting case because it's something
which has been right under my nose for
40 years and it took that amount of time
for me to have the right sort of
conceptual framework to see how it could
be applied in this particular case and
you know I I think that's I mean there's
there's also a question of kind of how
people you know how these Paradigm
shifts and so on kind of uh land in the
world I mean okay so there's one one big
one that I've been deeply involved in
which is the whole idea of using
computation and programs as models of
the world instead of using mathematical
equations as models of the world so you
roll the clock back you know 300 or so
years we get to Galileo and Newton and
so on and uh uh they had the problem of
explaining to people no you can't just
reason about how the world works you can
write down a mathematical equation and
solve it and that will tell you how the
moon moves or something and um you know
at that at that time it was a sort of
complicated battle to have people
realize yes you can just you know solve
the mathematical equation I'll tell you
how the world works it's not a question
of reasoning about it okay 300 years go
by and then we're at the point where oh
mathematical equations are the way the
world works is there some other way to
describe how the world Works no no no
there can't possibly be another way to
describe how the world works you know
when I started thinking about kind of
generalizing sort of rules for how the
world works and thinking about simple
programs and what they do and kind of
exploring the computational universe of
simple programs I would say actually
looking back on it it's interesting you
know I published this big book called
the new kind of science back in 2002 I
would say that many fields were really
quite receptive to what I had to say uh
fundamental physics was actually one of
the one of the only exceptions what was
interesting there was you know some
people said oh you know programs we
don't need programs to describe the
world mathematical equations do just
fine okay now you look just maybe 15
years later and if you look at new
models that people are inventing of
things they are overwhelmingly based on
programs not based on mathematical
equations there's a dark story
underneath this which is that as Tech
has been really the and by Tech I really
mean computation because most of the
rest of techn techology seems to have
vanished as computation became the one
bright spot in a relatively stagnant
World um and I I hate to say it that way
and there there are caveats but let's
let's keep
going it came to be that many people
started to dress up whatever they were
doing in terms of
computation right because it was
possible to seek you know funding from a
Yuri Milner or a Mark Zuckerberg or dare
I say a Jeffrey Epstein you know all of
these sorts of things um which had
exotic funding sources or possible
prizes around them in computation it
also became the case that funders were
more eager at the government level to
hear a proposal for something having a
computational nature so the problem that
we have is is that there were all these
old ideas about you know van noyman of
Schrodinger of Hawking etc etc um
touring about the world as a computer
and at the moment
there's a system of selective pressures
that partially has to do with how
difficult it is to fund one's research
so I I don't want I'm I'm very worried
about the event horizon of the
computational Paradigm it's absolutely
true what Stephen is saying that this
has Tor torn through theoretical physics
but I'm very dubious as I no it hasn't
no it hasn't not theoretical physics no
it hasn't the length people aren't
necessarily doing what you're saying but
they are dressing things up in terms of
computational so so I think interesting
points I think not quite right okay so
you're you're absolutely right that in
thetical physics for example Quantum
Computing has become this giant you know
fundable thing we can talk about that
separately or black hole information
paradoxes or the idea of the universe as
a computer John Wheeler had old points
but that feel but that's not what I'm
talking about that's not what I'm
talking about what I'm talking about is
there is a a way of thinking about doing
science that says you write down an
equation you can solve this equation
and it will tell you how the world is
going to work computational scientific
materialist well sort of the old line of
reductionism which is if we could just
solve these equations and we get
beautiful clo form Solutions the
surprising thing that you know I really
got serious about in the 1980s was this
this phenomenon where if what you think
is going on is that it's just following
computational rules then that doesn't
work anymore there's this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility where the
system is doing what it does and it's
doing a computation and we're trying to
figure out what the system does and
we're also doing a computation and
there's this thing I call the principle
of computational equivalence which is
basically the the statement or the claim
which we're getting more and more
evidence for that our ability to Think
Through what a system does is of the
same level of computational
sophistication as what the system itself
does so we never get to outrun the
system we don't get to do what has been
the kind of banner story of a lot of
traditional mathematical science which
is find this reduction this this
reducible computation where we can just
say and the system is going to do this
we're kind of stuck there's the issue
about whether we can compute it out once
we find the rules so the idea is that
you could imagine a world in which
Maxwell's equations are perfect you know
all the way down and you still might not
be able to compute the consequences of
Maxwell's equations inations like no
Stokes same it happens it happens but
it's very obscure in those equations
because when you look at like the Navia
Stokes equations the standard equations
for fluid flow one of the most notable
features of fluid flow is fluid
turbulence you know fluid flows quickly
it looks kind of random you say to
people who study the Navia stoes
equations can you reproduce that from
the underlying equations is that
something that's in the underlying
equations or is it maybe a sign of some
you know smaller scale molecular
processes that are getting Amplified etc
etc etc so they'll typically get I mean
these days they have a lot of empirical
ways to do it but if you really push on
the fundamental question they'll get
kind of embarrassed because they just
don't know it's like cork confinement if
you know the rules of quirks can you
prove that they are not never going to
be found in isolation and only going to
be found uh typically in hadrons and
yeah it's a that's a similar thing which
actually has that particular one
actually has a more direct story of of
of let's all agree that we're modern
people and we don't have the old
reductionist dream that's a non-trivial
point because theoretical physics that
point has not yet been understood well I
think it has I think that the extent to
which we talk about what is emergent
what is not what is anthropic what is
not we we now have many Concepts
including uh you know gal sorts of not
gwa um girdle sorts of concerns that are
cropping up in theoretical physics
finally yes I mean I wrote this paper
about unability in thetical physics back
in the early 1980s you know I think it
needs to be said you know Again by
somebody who hopes to be your competitor
that you were very early on a lot of
these topics you weren't doing it as
part of a fed you were in fact the
Pioneer coming out of the computational
ability of mathematic and all that
you've set up and you've wrapped some
beautiful libraries with many more
functions than anybody ever thought we
could have so you know kudos to you
there was a huge resistance inside of
theoretical physics because it was a
very closed arrogant Community uh it had
many reasons to be arrogant it has fewer
reasons to be arrogant now and so in
part I think that you were dismissed
unfairly it's very important that you
not be the one to blow your own horn so
I would be happy to say that I remember
when that book came out I remember the
derision the anger didn't seem to come
from anywhere in particular and it was
not listened to properly even though I I
don't think that it actually is doing
what you say it's doing now but one
happy to be wrong and it was always a
really important important point that
you were making within that I just don't
think that it really got hurt what do
you make of that Ste hold on I want to I
want to just correct that impression
because because the fact is you know I
was looking at this recently right what
you know sort of in so far as there was
negativism about that book where did it
actually come from because there was
tons of positivism I mean you know in in
it the the negativism it turns out was
specifically concentrated in people who
did fundamental physics
and if you look outside of that area it
was there wasn't it was not negativism
it was actually a lot of positivism but
the Steel Man the critics which I hate
to do the critics have a feeling that
there's a tiny number of fields where
it's very difficult to check people it's
very hard to say when a theoretical
physicist is bullshitting you it's very
hard to say when a theoretical you know
very pure mathematician is is speaking
nonsense so there is this fear how do we
know that what he's saying in some sense
is correct correct enough sorry Eric to
interrupt but correct enough to devote
many precious hours to unravel it that's
the there's that but there's not that
much to unravel at the moment so I'm not
that sympathetic with that you know this
is sort of Sabine I don't have time for
this stuff my feeling is the hell you
don't have time there's almost nothing
happening now with that said what I
think is is that there was a fear that
quite honestly people like you and like
myself are cheating and just I want to
be open about this the the fear that
comes out of whatever is left of the
core Community is you guys don't have a
right to go direct to Consumer you don't
have a right to talk about the field
that belongs to a tiny num the privilege
of a tiny number of people who do this
morning noon and night who are all
possessed of common beliefs and that's
something that both you and I have been
fighting now I would also suggest that
Stephen and I probably uh are not eager
to open the door to every lunatic with a
red crayon who wants to scribble
something on a roll of paper towels and
say that they've got a unified theory so
there have to be some standards on the
other hand the the core group that's
been trying to gate this is failed it
was historically interesting to me so I
was you know I did partical physics
during its kind of golden age in the
late 1970s when I was a late teenager so
to speak and I think I did pretty well
you know a bunch of I got you know got
was was uh sort of pretty successful in
the field and I wrote a bunch of papers
that still get cited because I lived in
the sort of golden age and not a lot
came after that I mean not because they
were necessarily uh you know it was a
question of picking low hanging fruit
and so that meant that I know a large
fraction of the kind of leading people
in theoretical physics above some age I
was quite surprised by the level of kind
of angst when new kind of science came
out but the typical thing that I heard
was oh my gosh if this is right what
we've been doing for the last 50 years
all has to be thrown away and and I kept
on saying I don't think that's what's
going to happen you know and and people
would say to me like um you know I I was
I was noticing I I think I I made a you
know wrote a sort of historical piece
about this and I described it as Nobel
Prize winners with pitchforks and so
there was a was a quite a parade it was
quite it's quite kind of interesting
looking back on it I was going to send
one of them an email actually just when
my new thing came out and then the
person went and died so they die or they
soften I think what was interesting to
me was at at that time 20 years ago
there was a lot of kind of uh you know
we're going to make it string theory is
going to do it we're almost there you
know we don't need anything else I think
that's changed now that's about 1984
through 86 when when the string Mania
was at its height no I think that you
know now you know we've got a lot of
mostly younger physicists who are pretty
seriously working on this stuff and I
think uh you know it's it's going great
of the older crowd you know I I sort of
been in contact with a large fraction of
them and it's like oh this seems
interesting and it's like you should
actually work on this I keep on telling
them you should actually work on it and
some of them have you know been on live
streams we've done and things like that
and we've certainly talked about things
but I think you know a lot of people
they do something for a living and this
isn't what they do for a living and I
don't know whether they'll kind of make
the effort to kind of turn what to
change what they do for a living I don't
know whether it matters I think that the
the concept that um uh you know it is
probably particularly 20 years ago it
was still the case that the kind of
institutional structure of things like
physics was very strong as in it was
like we have this institutional
structure and this is how this field is
going to work and we don't need anything
from the outside my impression is that
that's weakened in the intervening years
but maybe I'm wrong the perception that
I get from comments from people uh is
almost like uh being candid with both of
you as friends on one hand Eric is
criticized for a complexity a technical
uh you know sort of uh toolkit that is
beyond even many theoretical physicists
so you know I disagree that you know
they'll say I don't have enough time but
but it it is true that there's you know
General stock and trade of a theoretical
cosmologist is not necessarily hop
vibrations fiber bundles Etc it might be
pertubation Theory it might be Quantum
field Theory and on the other side of
the coin Stephen I think sometimes the
the perception is it's uh it's it's too
simplistic not in the sense or it's too
Elementary it's too fundamental in in
the sense that you use in your in your
wonderful new book which you're kind
enough to send to me and congratulations
for writing a shorter book than a new
kind of science I think by about P Brian
gets a copy I think Stephen will send
you one or I'll give you one when we get
together I've got multiple copies but
Stephen you know uh so let me let me
just start with with you for a second
Eric knows his critics he knows what
people say and I think he brings up a
good point wait I have critics this is
the first I hear of this BR there's two
one's named Pia something and the other
one but Stephen in your case I I think
it's it's absolutely correct that you
know people are blown away by the
contributions I have people you know
asking me to thank you from the depths
of their heart for for Mathematica for
new kind of science that in some ways
it's amazing that you guys have I get
comments I'm reading them you save my
life you touch my life you change my
life it's so amazing but on the other
hand I think that that in in you know
real scientific circles often times
breeds a class of of almost undermining
and and let me explain something which
is which I think is interesting the so I
am that people think what I've done is
simplistic is a great compliment because
I've spent a huge amount of effort
trying to take the things that I'm
thinking about and make them simple
enough that both I can understand them
well and I can explain them well when I
wrote new kind of science I even said
this in the introduction I said the fact
that this appears to be very simple
appears to be very straightforward will
make people who thought you know who who
work on technical science think that you
know there must they must really
understand this and this must be
something simple and irrelevant it isn't
true you know the fact is it is it is
much more difficult at least for me
maybe it isn't for everybody but I think
it probably is for almost everybody to
to turn things into things that can be
described simply than it is to kind of
you know maybe there's a certain
challenge to sort of building up the
tower of being able to talk about you
know fiber bundles and selfdual
connections and all this kind of thing
but but that's a it's a well-defined
tower you have to climb so so for
example right now I happen to be working
on kind of a very bizarre thing that
again I I never thought would come out
which is a kind of a a a general theory
of meta mathematics so in mathematics
one one thinks about you know there's
the particular mathematics people do the
the 3 million theorems of mathematics
that have been published in the
literature of mathematics in in human
history but then there's the kind of
full meta mathematics of all possible
theorems and the remarkable thing is
that it looks like we can actually
derive kind of the analog of Einstein's
equations in meta mathematical space
very bizarre we keep coming to this
point I want to just um put put a a pin
here just in case it's of Interest I
don't think that it's very difficult to
imagine recovering Einstein's equations
given Hilbert's contribution so that we
know in a weird sense that Einstein did
something very very difficult and I've
compared it to half doome where there's
a sheer face that Einstein went up and
then there's this gentle face that
Hilbert went up after he knew that it
could be climbed it seems to me that
because we know that Einstein's
equations results from the simplest
objective function that you could have
which is the scalar curvature in ranian
geometry that that's not a great Target
I mean it's great that you can produce
something that looks like Einstein's
theory out of computation rules the next
one on the list would be would be Yang
Mills Theory I mean there're only really
four four basic equations again the
objetive the objective function the
objective function is as simple as it
gets so to Steven's Point what we know
about the current physical world is is
that two out of the four equations
fundamental equations for the fields the
things that dance in our world and we
call particles or waves both of those
come from the simplest possible
curvature equations that one can have in
Geometry so if you think that geometry
is largely about curvature then the two
simplest structures that can generate
equations called the Yang Mills lran or
the Yang Mills Max Maxwell lran which is
just you you you take the size of the
curvature and you square it and that's
it the other one is you just take a
piece of theur curvature without
squaring it when you have a piece to
take called the scalar curvature and
that's it the other two equations are
have a slightly different character I
want to leave aside the the um the higs
field and the what would you call the
Klein Gordon equation with the potential
but I would say the next order of
business is do you find the darac
equation because it's very difficult to
find Spinners Spinners yes arising from
computational Rules well no that's
so the answer is do we know how we
manage to get spinner representations
the rotation group we know how to
construct these things there is a
mystery about why they are there to
construct now there are people who will
go to their grave saying there is no
mystery I know how to construct it
therefore I know what it is which is
never true I mean we we only really
understand something in mathematics when
we can walk all around it and see it
from many different angles I agree that
we know how to construct Spinners I know
how to construct dck operators but this
is a highly
non-trivial question in our world it
comes out of what I call the Psychedelic
of mathematics the Square Root
construction where you ask a question
like what is x^2 uh equals minus one it
has no solution in the reals you have to
jump into another space in order to
answer the question right so it has this
different character which is the answer
to the problem isn't found in the Pro in
the space in which the problem was posed
in the case of Einstein's equations and
in the Yang Mill's equations or the
souped up version of Maxwell's equations
nonlinear Maxwell theory if you will you
have something which has a character
where I understand where it comes from
in the case of the darac equation you've
got much bigger problems I tried to
bring this up on the last live stream
didn't didn't work at all what do you do
in quantum gravity when you don't have
an observation of the metric for example
and therefore you cannot construct the
ocean in which the electron is a wave
now if you think about it very carefully
in a weird way electrons are basically
functions and photons are basically
derivative operators okay a bizarre way
to think about it I mean you can think
about I mean I I I know the mathematical
physics so I understand what you're
talking about but but I think then you
wouldn't say it's a bizarre way at all I
don't think in any in any event what
we're talking about is talking about
versions of the XY plane and functions
and derivatives right and the idea of
the XY plane that grows up to become
something called fiber bundles which
Step mentioned at the beginning the idea
of functions grows up to be something
called sections and the idea of
derivatives grows up to be something
called connections now these are the
basic bread and butter of what goes on
before you get to the quantum and in
that picture there's a big difference
between recovering the easiest bits and
Rec covering the hardest bits so I don't
mean to to put extra weight on Steph's
shoulders if he can do the first bits
that's great but there's a series of
challenges that are of escalating
difficulty in terms of recovery because
of the Simplicity of some portions of
our model and the Baroque complexity of
other portions of the model for example
the internal quantum number assignments
that give the particles their
personality the number of generations
the chirality of the situation it's very
interesting Stephen's um rules are going
to have to pick a left or a right so
it's very interesting to how he's going
to recover a chairo world this is silly
you know let let me let me give give you
my my point of view here okay you know
we can talk about details of
mathematical physics um it's quite
interesting I know you know a bunch
about it you know we can go deeply into
you know how you know half enter just
spin versus ENT just in particles work
etc etc etc I mean what you're doing is
you're making the Paradigm Shift mistake
right you're talking about things in
terms of kind of existing mathematical
physics ideas and yes we you know you're
saying oh my gosh you'll never be able
to get Spinners no I'm saying no no I
don't think he's saying let me just make
a few points about this go ahead Ste
okay I mean the fact is the you know
we're actually hot on the trail of
understanding how fans versus bans work
it's quite quite interesting it has to
do it seems with cases where in our and
again sort of a somewhat complicated
story but it's a you know these these
Branch Pairs and branchial space whether
they end up being things that merge
after a small number of steps or not
seems to be the what is the
distinguishing feature between bosons
and Fons how that relates to hen just
spin we don't completely know it seems
to be related to various features of
homotopy in the multi-way causal graph
and uh you know it it's quite possible
that some of the kinds of mathematical
physics that you like a lot are highly
relevant in understanding how that
homotopy works in the multi-way causal
graph it looks like a limit of the
multi-way causal graph is quite possibly
related to twister Theory and uh that
one can understand some of the things
that happen there on the basis of
Twister Theory whether we can get we're
now understood we've understood quite a
bit about how rotational invariance
Works how angular momentum works but
it's it's kind of a weird business
because in a sense we're trying to build
from the machine code up and you know we
can have a detailed mathematical physics
conversation where's the sill what most
people are are interested in here oh I I
disagree I think that people actually
want to see whether or not you know both
of us are saying outlandish things by
the way I don't think what I was saying
was silly at at all so gu it's standard
mathematical physics it's all standard
mathematical physics and the fact I'm
going to invoke my I'm going to hold on
hold on one second I do want to I do
want to point something out I think it's
it's very important I've heard this from
people that I hold in high esteem Paul
steinart uh one reason that Paul says he
refuses to ever get a Facebook or or
Twitter account is because he would
invariably be tempted to propose an
interesting idea which by necessity
would be new novel untested unproven at
some level and then immediately would be
attacked assailed uh subjugated to to uh
to to constraints and concerns and I
think you guys have both seen that uh
for the following reason that you both
are uh master explicator of what you do
you both are obviously domain experts in
what you know and and you understand the
other branches of physics and
Mathematics that are pertinent to it
however neither one really knows the
other one's the intimacy of the other
one's theories and I think it's
important to realize that just like
people assailing your theories from
without I think it's too soon to tell at
least in the case of of Steven's uh work
which is you know in some sense 20 years
old or coming up on 20 years old and in
some in some sense it's also brand new
because I think when you look at the
successful applications I feel like we
should just check those off Stephen I
mean biological systems crystallography
you go down the list Finance economics
where the uh wlrm approach the new kind
of science approach first outlined in in
2003 or so uh that has already been
proven it doesn't need to be proven
where I think it's different is where we
lay on this extra ler of computability
as a fundamental nature of the universe
which for my perception maybe Stephen
correct me if I'm wrong has sort of a
Multiverse component to it you talk
about different different aspects of the
universe well you talk in your in an
essay that you wrote in in 2017 about
you know the space of all universes uh
where these rules that was before I
understood what I Now understand yeah so
but we are barely coming up to where you
were in 2017 so can we take a step back
uh we we talked about the Paradigm issue
I want to talk a little bit more about
uh about how these ideas get into the
firmament or get into the Zeitgeist yeah
before you do that I I I want to just
clear something up right Stephen I'm not
trying to Scuttle your theory I believe
that your your theory if if you have an
approach that works and it's a face up
the same Mountain my belief is is that
you will get to to answer these
questions you may tell us for the first
time spiritually what a spinner is from
a computational perspective I'm not
saying you've only done the easy stuff
and the other stuff is really hard the
stuff that you're talking about is
really hard what's going to pick out the
remon curvature tensor how however
youate that one's Fair easy well I
believe it because it's very natural
there's a reason that in some sense it
came first um before the the woy Yang
dictionary I think Spinners are going to
come out as I mean the latest thing
which is only a week old so it's still
uncooked so we're tricking him to
sharing this on the live this is
exclusive this is an here well we
probably talked about it on our working
session live streams but first point is
in our models quantum mechanics is a
very natural thing in in sort of when we
think about traditional classical
mechanics it's like you throw a ball it
goes in a definite Direction in quantum
mechanics kind of the idea is that the
ball you know tests out all possible
paths and then we only get to see
various probabilities about what happens
okay and models there are these things
called multi-way systems which basically
are enumerating all the possible paths
and the the co whole sort of dynamics of
how quantum mechanics Works comes out of
these multi-way systems now the what
what happens is when you look at one of
these multi-way systems at a particular
time you take a slice through it and you
get this thing we call branchial space
branchial space is the analog in the
space of quantum states to physical
space in kind of ordinary uh position in
in in the universe by physical space you
mean space like hypers space these
branchial surfaces are the analog their
branch-like hypersurfaces which are the
analog of space-like hypersurfaces in
standard SpaceTime okay so this
branch-like hypersurface in branchial
space there's an extent in branchial
space which is where as you as you move
through branchial space you're moving
through the space of sort of quantum
entanglements and so states that are
further away in branchial space are less
Quantum entangled than states which are
close in branchell space what is your
notion of a distance well it's based on
if you look at the multi-way graph the
um the the the nearest Neighbors in
branchial space are things which have a
common ancestor one step back in the in
the multi-way graph so those are what we
called Branch pairs I mean this is
unfortunately it gets it gets fairly no
no I appreciate that but the idea is you
have some ordering by number of steps
metric
yesc based on sort of common ancestry in
the multi-way graph and um uh
essentially what happens is well that
that thing on the left is a multi-way
causal graph the thing on the right is a
kind of play version of a um of a kind
of mixture of branchial space and
physical space not the best best
visualization but it's it's it's
something but anyway so so the the idea
is there's physical space that we're all
familiar with there's this branchial
space which is the kind of space of
quantum States just like there's a speed
of light in physical space in our model
there's a maximum entanglement speed in
branchial space which is kind of the
maximum speed that at which kind of you
can maximum speed of kind of
entanglement in that in that space so
okay why is any of this relevant again
this is I'm I'm in in the Einstein
equations which have to do with physical
space one is looking at and one way to
view the Einstein equations is to think
about what happens to a GDC what happens
to the path of a particle in SpaceTime
essentially what's happening in the
Einstein equations is that that energy
momentum causes deflections in the in
the in gd6 in SpaceTime in uh branchial
space the exact same thing happens
essentially energy momentum causes uh
deflections in gd6 in branchial space
and it turns out that that deflection
process gives one the fan path undergr
which is really cool and one of the
things that I sort of found the most
elegant in the things that we've done so
far in this in this theory that what in
the in physical space is the Einstein
equations in branchial space is the path
integral okay why is this relevant to
Fons and bosons the reason it's relevant
is that wait wait I just want to take a
moment to think about what you just said
you said that something in general
relativity that is Einstein's equations
which are maximally resistant of all of
our structures to
quantization is analogous in some ways
to the Fineman path integral which I'm
going to disagree later with your
characterization which is Fineman sort
of characterization the linguistic
description of what we claim is
happening when we're taking one of these
integrals but the point is is that
you're just making a claim osant which
is astounding to begin with so if true
right which is that the Einstein
equations are somehow intimately bound
up in the the qu the the quintessential
centerpiece of Quantum field Theory not
even Quantum mechanic yep yep yep they
are the Einstein equations that I mean
this is a remarkable thing which I
certainly did not see coming that the
part is is is the exact same thing as
the Einstein equations but in a
different kind of space never heard this
right so that that's one of the things
that we discovered like I don't know six
seven months ago that was like Wow and
those two things meet up when you think
about black holes and black hole
information and so on there's sort of
this and in fact the ads CFT
correspondence is almost certainly
taking this multi-way causal graph and
projecting it into SpaceTime and project
projecting it into branchial space that
it's the same graph projected in two
different ways corresponds to the kind
of general relativity ads side of ads
CFT and the quantum field Theory CFT
side of it that's that's almost
certainly what that is and various
people are working on filling in the
details of that it's pretty neat so then
okay you asked about fans and bosons and
I was going to tell you this week's kind
of way of getting to that and you know
these are complicated things so it takes
a few steps yeah okay so the the next
thing to realize is in quantum mechanics
you know one of the things that emerged
particularly from Von neyman's work was
this idea of you know there is an
amplitude it is a complex number it you
know operates in hbit space etc etc etc
one of the things that was implicitly
done was something which I think turns
out to be a mistake which is that the
magnitude and the faith
of these Quantum amplitudes were sort of
all packaged together you the
projectivization of a hrid space yes yes
I mean the fact that well the fact that
the fact you can think about it as a a
magnitude and phase is just a complex
number What in in our models the what
ends up happening is the magnitude and
the phase come from completely different
places and so what happens is the
magnitude has to do with the counting of
paths going through this multi-way graph
the phas has to do with essentially
where you land up in bronal space and
actually one of the things that um we
figured out about a week or two ago is
it's just unbelievably easy to get the
double slit experiment to work and we
get nice pictures I don't know what that
means but the F the first interference
in quantum mechanics right I understand
that right not that's not you mean you
don't understand how it's uh easy it
comes out naturally in some sense no
what he's saying I mean we have to go
back and unpack what what the good
doctor is saying he is talking about the
fact that we claim that we work in a
Hilbert space we don't work in a Hilbert
space we work in something called the
projectivization of a Hilbert space and
effectively that destroys a certain
amount of structure so we begin with
something like a vector space we remove
the origin we pluck it out like the seed
out of a cherry and then we take you
know all of the sort of meat and we
compress it in this particular way and
what Steph is saying is is that that is
a loss of information that we teach
physicists with their mother's milk and
that this may be in fact uh throwing
away information that is actually
experimentally much more important more
I mean I think that the let's not get in
let's not go off into projective Hill
with space for a minute um the the uh
let's um I mean the you guys never take
me
anywhere um buy me to the hbert space
right the thing that ends up being
interesting is the um uh when you think
about kind of these these again this is
uh the kind of the the sort of quantum
G6 what ends up happening is the phase
of the quantum amplitude is essentially
defined by its position in branchial
space so you think about these in in
general relativity you'd think about you
know a gd6 is deflected by the presence
of mass you know it's attracted to some
massive object moves around it it
changes the the direction of the GDC Has
Changed by the presence of mass okay in
in branchial space it's the same
the the the GDC is deflected by the
presence of energy momentum that
presence of energy momentum corresponds
to the lran in Quantum field Theory and
what one is doing is deflecting that GD
the deflection of the GD um CH the
interpretation of that is it's changing
the phase of the quantum amplitude it's
changing where that JC is going to land
in bran Shield space which changes the
phase of the quantum amplitude and
amusingly enough what appears in the
fthr is exactly e to the I over H bar
times the action integral the action
integral is the integral in our world of
the Divergence of causal edges which
corresponds to the lanan there seem to
be multiple things going on here if I
can just I do want to invoke my uh my
privilege here being the moderator uh
We've covered the first of our six or
seven topics in 40 in an hour and 15
minutes it's clear to me I just want to
finish on bons for a second please yeah
please finish and let's move to our next
which be experimental testability the
flavor of of of this
is that what ends up happening with bans
is this kind of collection in branchial
space this this kind of uh uh focusing
in branchial space and what seems to
happen with firion is a Divergence in
branchial space and it's you know one of
the things that I've been always been
curious about is why are there only Fons
and bosons why isn't there lots of you
know intermediate Paras statistics and
so on and I think that the answer is
that it's going to end up being the case
that basically in branchial space things
either diverge or they don't diverge and
that's going to but you know there's
there's much mathematical physics
packing that has to go around this if I
could just take 15 seconds to riff off
this okay you have a situation in which
the great thing about general relativity
for example is is that all you need is
length and angle and length and angle
turns out to amount to a derivative
operator which turns out to have mixed
partials that don't commute you can
measure their failure that's the
curvature you knock it down with linear
algebra and you create gravity it's a
miracle it's
fantastic on the other hand it's not
that surprising that if you have a
situation in which you have some notion
of like size and
perpendicularity that you can create
something like that for example you do
have something called mobus distance
that you can get out of data you can
treat a covariance matrix like a
Romanian metric if you will so there are
all sorts of ways in which we already
know that there that the discreet that
anything that leads to length and angle
becomes geometric and I think that you
know that's both very good for Dr
Wolfram and it is also just a bit of
caution for the rest of us that on the
the the early part may lead you on
because it's it's a different way of
describing length and angle and the
consequences which thanks to both
Einstein Grossman and I guess Hilbert um
we know that all we're looking for in
some sense is the most basic consequence
of that it'll be cool to see it come out
and I do believe that you you you may
likely get fermion out of a question you
may have to ask the question about how
to take the square root of something
I'll be astounded if you have Fons
without taking a square root but the key
feature you know is that you're not that
far away from geometry as soon as you're
talking about mobus distance and
covariance Matrix and data okay so so
you know the one cool thing is that the
uncertainty principle in our theory is
basically the analog of of rean
curvature in bronal space
so the the non-commuting of variables is
just like noncommuting and in geometric
quantization it is literally the Curve
Your tensor uh on in the hamiltonian
picture absolutely by the way in terms
of the square root thing I I I have the
following guess okay that what basically
happens in branchial spaces you have
these Branch Pairs and they converge
okay Branch pairs Next Step they
converge I think that the Bon case is
they they diverge and they converge the
firmon cases they diverge and they don't
converge and so in some sense the square
root is being taken by the fact that
you're having the the beginning of that
diamond but not the end of the diamond
sounds like the difference between
commutators and anticommutator yeah yeah
it's the it's the it's my my first guess
about how that works and it'll it's I
mean the thing that again I thought we
were going to have to you know find
actual electrons to be able to
distinguish Fons and bosons it's seeming
increasingly like likely that we can
basically understand fans in bulk
without having to know exactly how
particles work what I want to do now is
sort of compare uh and contrast
different approaches not necessarily
only the from the two of you but in the
in the context that I often get well
first of all the the common thing that I
get from all my you know friends on
Reddit or wherever else this gets posted
is you know how come these things aren't
being peer- reviewed and what kinds of
falsifiable predictions are they making
let's start with the latter uh Stephen
you and I talked back in April and you
made it clear that things such as the
fundamental conents of nature the speed
of light are emergent or are embedded
encoded encrypted within uh within your
uh new findings I want to know are there
new predictions that could be used in
sad of retrodictions not that they don't
have validity not that they don't have a
value after all Einstein you know in
some sense validated his uh his theory
on a retrodiction which was known for
million you know millions of years it
was known for years the per helan
advance of the planet Mercury and it had
to be reconciled with uh with Einstein's
uh predictions and through observations
it was found to be true I want to know
uh Stephen are there new fundamental
predictions that you can can point to
that have at least in principle a chance
of being detected and then I'll have a
similar question for Eric well let's see
I don't do the the dueling theories
Theory but but I'm not going to yeah I'm
not some falsifiability is a weird
concept that
has all kinds of problems but the fact
is you know first thing is the number
one thing that we're building is a
framework like
calculus calculus is not something
that's
falsifiable calculus is a framework for
doing things second question is does
calculus usefully apply to the universe
that's something we can validly ask and
that's something that you know we can
there are things which are sort of
generic prediction
from the framework so the thing we're
trying to do right now is what people
should do when they first introduce some
you know new set of ideas which is can
we actually reproduce can we make
theoretical predictions can we reproduce
What what what has been known before and
can we get out vastly more than we put
in yes we put very little in and the
question is do we get all these things
out or do we have to add some special
clug to get Fons or do Fons come out
naturally
as soon as we understand how to get
there and the thing which has been
remarkable so far is you know we've been
checking off do we get this do we get
that do we get that so far touchwood no
clues I mean so far it's been hard work
but nothing has been like oh my gosh the
universe you know the theory predicts
the universe should be 26 dimensional we
have to explain why it's not type thing
we haven't had any of those kind of you
know clu barriers so to speak so that's
encouraging now in terms of actually
making specific measurable predictions
um there a couple of issues first issue
is going from the raw Theory the
low-level machine code to something
where you turn a telescope in that
direction and you see a particular thing
there's lots of you know there's lots of
hard work and lots of astrophysics and
so on to be done in in going from one
place to another that's first point the
second point is that um to actually make
one of the things in our theory is there
is one scale same happened with
Einstein's theory actually although for
various reasons it well we can talk
about that but there's one scale which
is this maximum entanglement speed um we
don't know what the value of that is we
have some guesses but we don't know its
value if we knew its value we would have
a whole bunch of predictions immediately
but we don't know its value um Einstein
had the same problem he had the
cosmological constant he didn't know its
value it's uh you know a lot of
predictions he might have liked to make
he couldn't make cuz he didn't know the
value of the cosmological constant uh
you know he had one meta prediction was
that the Universe wasn't expanding he
thought which is why he added his
cosmological constant in the first place
but that's his scale so then he had a
few scale independent predictions in
particular the you know the bending of
light around the Sun being a factor of
two larger than I've been predicted in
the previous Theory things like that so
one thing that we've been interested in
is what scale independent predictions
can we make that's question one and
question two what predictions can we
make that are as soon as we know this
one scale we immediately have
predictions and then which predictions
can we make that have the shortest
distance in terms of the Tower of
astrophysics or particle physics or
whatever they have to be done it's it's
a cautionary tale that like Newton for
example you know he goes through his
whole you know prier and he works out
lots of things about his law of gravity
and he has a section about the moon and
the section about the moon ends with the
sentence I think but the ABS of the moon
is twice as great right other words he
got the wrong answer and and you know
one might have said oh my gosh you got
the wrong answer you better abandon the
whole Theory and run away so to speak
turns out it was just hard to do those
calculations it took another 150 years
to get them nailed down so that wasn't
you know so one has to be a little bit
and Einstein also you know the first
time he computed the bending of light
around the sun he got it wrong and it
was you know fortunate the first you
know experiment that was going to be
done on that didn't end up getting done
because of World War I and uh uh and so
you know by the time an experiment did
get done he'd managed to get the right
answer whether the experiment was right
it's a different story but that's that's
another another thing but I think that
the um so the question of you know do we
have kind of scale independent
predictions the answer is quite possibly
um I think there's one quite likely one
that has to do with uh two Photon
correlations for photons in orbit around
rotating black holes which is a slightly
obscure thing but it's not completely
out of the range of what's
experimentally accessible other I mean
it's kind of amusing that that's so
bizarrely similar it's a kind of a
Quantum analog of Einstein's you know
bending of light around the Sun type
thing um but uh you know that's one kind
of thing another thing is a a suggestion
at least from the theory about the
existence of particles much lighter than
the electron maybe 10 to the 20th times
lighter than the electron dep that
number depends on the scale parameter
that we don't know the existence of such
particles probably has a bunch of
implications for dark matter um which
are things that we're planning to work
out there are a bunch of implications
for cosmology I mean there's an
expectation not a necessary feature but
a suggestion at least from the model
that the Universe started kind of
infinite dimensional and only gradually
kind of Decay down to the sort of modest
three dimensions that we have now um
that has a bunch of implications for
inflationary scenarios for the universe
and so on you know I think the most
outlandish possibility which I don't
think will actually happen is that that
still at the time of recombination you
know when when your Cosmic microwave
background Globe was was was minted so
to speak that there would still be a
trace of some of the early discrete
processes that happened in the very
early stages of the Universe I really
doubt that it would have survived that
long but if it did the absolutely
outlandish possibility is that the kind
of the rule for the universe might be
painted in the microwave background
radiation which would be truly I don't
think that would happen I think it's
very unlikely but you know early density
perturbations there might be some things
that would be a result of this changing
dimensional uh scenario that's rather
different from the traditional
exponential expansion in
four-dimensional space SpaceTime of of
inflationary cosmology that's on the one
side on the particle physics side and
and well one of the things is that it's
looking very much as if quantum
Computing at some fundamental level
can't work however seeing that and
seeing the actual effects of of our
theory for decoherence and things like
that it's not at all clear that the the
can't work point is something
experimentally accessible and uh I think
that the um uh you know it's a question
is there some clever experiment that can
be done in um in Quantum Computing that
could see this maximum entanglement
speed that's basically the and we don't
know what the value of that speed is so
we can't really tell one estimate that
we have of that speed is 10 the five
solar masses per second if that estimate
is correct then it is possible that in
Black Hole uh well it's possible there
will a small effect in a black hole
merger of you know one and a half solar
mass type size would have a a bigger
effect if you know two sort of central
black holes of two galaxies happen to
collide and merge then there would be a
bigger effect it's also conceivable that
there might be effect an effect when
black holes initially form and this is
an astrophysics question for you Brian
how long does it take a black hole to
actually form once once you have
infalling matter um the question is what
the actual whether in 10us 5 seconds
something whe whether one can tell
what's happening in the last 10 the- 5
Seconds of the formation of a black hole
if one can and if our estimate of the
maximum entanglement speed is right then
there will probably be differences from
the predictions of general relativity
for that case this is a big question
primordial black hole
formation the end of inflation uh these
are really important questions that you
know it's good to it's good to hear
especially that you're you know
providing potential full employment for
my graduate students down a lot yes
there will be lots of work to do in
figuring out the consequences of these
things I mean it's a particular when we
get this kind of way of actually doing
computations in general relativity from
our model set up as a piece of practical
numerical relativity and that that will
probably happen fairly quickly we'll
actually be able to see a bunch of these
effects directly in the computations
that we do but there'll be you know just
layers of astrophysics to
do and Eric I want you to uh to to sort
of aine on this this provocative
question that I'm being asked in the
chat room and that is you know what uh
of what value is a theory uh if it is
not to be testable you know that which
can be claimed without evidence can be
dismissed without evidence as our friend
Christopher Hitchens used to say I
believe uh so in the context of
geometric Unity not asking you to talk
about somebody else's book but talk talk
your own book for a second are there
things that are uh testable by graduate
students in my group or or other
brilliant students around the world are
there predictions are there
retrodictions that are crisp enough to
to satisfy popper a and do you think we
should continue to feed popper as he had
enough po po popper corn the first point
would be there's a missing layer between
uh you and myself what we do typically
um Stephen notwithstanding is is that we
come up with a classical model in the
form of some sort of geometry hopefully
it quantizes itself there something like
GE geometric quantization and then we
try to figure out what the testable
consequences are at any given energy
level uh through a bunch of
phenomenologists experimentalists and
pure Quantum field theorists working
hand inand in our harmonious fashion at
least that's the the given that we have
a missing layer there's tons I can say
about what's new what's different and
what my theory says and effectively what
would make it wrong so I'm happy to get
into that because it effectively says
that a lot of our standard
verbiage around what we found is in fact
wrong so for example standard thing is
the world is chyal the weak Force sees
the difference between our left hand and
our right hand spiritually speaking my
claim is is that the world is not
fundamentally chyro it is emergently
chyal and that in fact it begins in a
non-chiral fashion which solves the
problem that Saina does not see which is
what chooses whether it's going to be
the left half or the right half
effectively that uh you know makes up Us
in some sense don't we already know from
nutrino masses that we're not seeing a
completely chyal situation we can get
into the issue of how to interpret
nutrino masses my claim would be that we
have entire sectors that we're not
seeing so for example unadorned spin one
half bundles that would be uh tensored
with if you will the conjugate of the 16
dimensional representation which imparts
the particles uh their personalities so
that is not something that's seen and
I've analogized it for those of you
watching at home rather than listening
where you have a hand and you see with
three fingers in the middle that you
think there's a symmetry in the hand and
then you have this problem about how do
I make my pinky look like my thumb and
you don't realize that there's an entire
other hand and that it's thumb to thumb
and Pinky to pinky not pinky to thumb
it's the symmetry so there there is a
non- chyal world that is emergently
chyal which is fooling us into thinking
it's fundamentally chyal there are only
two Generations not three generations
people will immediately say well how do
you explain the fact that we've seen the
tow particle in the top and bottom forks
and cl is that is not a generation
because it will not unify as you heat
the soup up in the same way as the first
two generations will unify in fact it
will unify with another collection of
particles also spin one half which I
believe if I recall correctly the thing
that will be misinterpreted as an
internal representation I think will be
like 112 dimensional rather than 16
there will be no internal
representations there will be no
internal symmetries this has been a huge
trip up for things like super symmetry
where we keep looking for these super
Partners which I've analogized a little
bit to what happens if you're
convinced that uh Spider Moon um should
be in fact Clark Kent you know should be
accompanied by Clark Kent and Peter
Parker should be accompanied by Superman
we have this wrong WR there is no
internal symmetry nor should you expect
internal symmetry because this comes out
of two unification two fundamental
origin stories one for the space-time
manifold another for effectively the Y
AIS above that as the x- axis so we we
decide that somehow we have SpaceTime in
Einstein and then somehow we get this
thing called su3 cross su2 cross U1 that
falls out of the sky which is a second
origin story there is not two Origin
stories there is one Einstein I believe
one of the problem Stephen I'm going to
say is that we have been in a very
difficult position relative to Einstein
because like unlike anyone else because
of the thought experiments we have a
reverence for not only what he gave us
in terms of equations how he thought in
the beautiful Humanity that he imparted
to everyone so we don't we don't want to
harm him in any way it's also the fact
that he was wrong and he was wrong in an
interesting way in the same way I
believe that Newton was wrong and we
souped up Newton with Einstein but that
physics is taking place in my opinion on
two separate spaces you can call X and Y
Brian I've joked with you calling it uh
har and hasham the Heaven and the
Earth in these two spaces there is a map
between and that is the map that in fact
Einstein started playing with but he did
not think to pull back the information
from space two onto space one from space
X to space y I believe that there is a
deoration complex which in ukian
signature is elliptic which in fact
tells us why the self-dual equations and
the churn Simon gauge theory that were
studied in the late 70s early 80s are so
important in fact it was a special
example of a much more General structure
comes out of geometric Unity that there
is not two kinds of geometry in this
situation one ronian geometry underlying
general relativity uh and osmanian
geometry of fiber bundles underlying the
standard model there is in fact one
geometry and that one geometry is why
it's called geometric unity and it has
to do with the difficulty of a lie that
we tell in general relativity which is
that we say that it is a so-called gauge
Theory where we try to get the gauge
group to be something called the
dimorphism group or general coordinate
invariance we allow it to act on the
space of metrics whereas in the case of
the standard model we have a space not
of metrics but of derivative operators
from calculus called connections and the
group we have is the gauge group and the
gauge group is an infinite dimensional
Beast that acts on the space connection
we do not understand in fact that
telling this lie to make general
relativity look like uh a gauge theory
in fact block progress and that we
should treat it as an honest gauge
Theory we are going to have to recognize
that the cosmological constant is not
constant it is a field which acquires a
Bev or a vacuum expectation value as it
is lured Away by topological mechanisms
we are going to see that we got the
Loren group wrong we focus focused on
the lorence group when we meant to be
focusing on the gauge group we formed
its in homogeneous extension called it
the poner group in fact you're supposed
to extend it by something called ad
valued one forms to create effectively
the inhomogeneous gauge group that is
the object on which you're supposed to
do super symmetric analysis and so our
concept of super symmetry is wrong in
effect we're acting on the wrong group
we've chosen minkovsky space as the
naturally occurring Aline space it is
not not the right place to be playing
the right place to be playing is the
space of connection there's a huge
number of things I can tell you about
the missing matter what in our sector
it's su3 cross su2 cross U1 internal
quantum numbers will be you know 16 new
particles that are spin three halves
with conjugate internal quantum numbers
so the same thing is our usual 16
dimensional representation but the
complex conjugate thereof uh which we
have not seen yet and explaining why the
illusion of three generations is
generated by what would be called
branching rules with respect to Lee
algebra and Lee group representation
decomposition so yes I can tell you a
bunch of new particles I can tell you
about non- chirality the number of
Generations how Einstein is wrong what
spaces were supposed to be doing this on
and then there's the question about okay
well what can you tell us about the
accelerators and by the way this is all
subject to if my theory is correct but
it gets boring to say if my theory is
correct over and over again so there
should just be a general caveat that all
of this assumes geometric Unity is in
fact correct so yes there's a ton of
specificity and Brian I'm looking
forward to coming down to UCSD and and
actually doing but let me just say
something yeah I've been very pissed off
about this claim that what I'm talking
about different from what uh Dr Wolfram
is talking about is so impenetrable and
difficult
it isn't and it really has to do with
the sickness in our field that our field
just isn't interested in some sense
because it doesn't believe we all know
that the problems have gotten so
difficult and so hard and so many smart
people have been over them that a sense
of learned helplessness has invaded the
field which we have to talk about people
no longer feel like they're actual
physicist that can connect to
Schrodinger or Heisenberg or dck or
Einstein or Clon people don't even feel
like Weinberg and yang who were still
with us are in some sense nobody's gone
to I see losing the Nobel Prize over
Brian shoulder nobody's gone to
Stockholm for advances in fundamental
physical Theory since theories put
forward since the early 1970s I think
that's a correct statement so all the
people who've contributed to the
fundamental Cannon are either dead or
septo generian or or or higher I I think
um maybe Frank wilch was born in 1951 is
at the end of his 60 we have to
recognize that this sense that it is
impossible has caused lots of us to
start faking it and to start calculating
what we need to do for our careers
rather than how to actually Advance the
science which is one reason that both uh
Stephen and I are viewed as incredibly
Brash effectively too brusk maybe too
arrogant and the answer I believe is
that we have to drive this field out of
its sense that it's playing at physics
rather than doing physics it's talking
around physics and one of the things I
want to do on these live streams is I
want to actually talk about the meat of
the theories and let people Scurry to
Wikipedia or help each other out to try
to understand what is said rather than
make enjoyable product for every I agree
I agree but Stephen has said earlier you
know this this is simple okay it's not
easy it's not it's not uh you know it's
not trivial my nine-year-old uh who
you'll meet someday hopefully both of
you guys he can play around with rule 30
he can get stimulated he can uh engage
with it so when you say you know that
it's not difficult I don't agree that
that there's a character class that
differentiates and I'm not pitting it
one against another for certain there
are more complicated models than even
Erics uh in my opinion how's my model
complicated I'm just a simple
experimentalist 14 dimensional uh you
know dual spaces and uh look if it's too
complicated for Sabina to understand uh
I think our general wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait this is just unfair and I
want to be very clear about it if you
talk about general relativity which
Stephen has been talking about
throughout our live stream he's talking
about the idea that you have a space
call it X and it has a metric on and
that metric is a map into the space of
all possible metrics call that y that X
and that y are where geometric Unity
lives so with all due respect to Sabina
and her you know I can't understand
anything it's all so complicated cut the
crap you've got a map between space time
and a space of metrics that Rani metric
is simply a map between two topological
spaces it's not that complicated I don't
Brian it's just not true okay let's move
on actually I want to make a few
comments about okay Stephen go ahead so
maybe people will find interesting I
mean so you know you know Maps between
topological spaces defom morphisms these
kinds of ideas right you know I happen
to learn these ideas when I was a kid
most people don't
mhm these are fairly you know most
people learn those ideas in I don't know
mid you know math College if they go to
a a fancy College maybe math graduate
school those kinds of things they happen
to be fairly complicated you know there
are fields of science where people can
contribute without having gone to
graduate school there are other fields
where they can't contribute very much we
see that in people one of the great
things about kind of some of these
computational areas of science is that
because it's kind of uh you know because
it's very new territory it's possible
for people to contribute without having
kind of gone to graduate school and
learned a whole big stack of Concepts
one of the things you know I get pretty
much every day you know a Theory of
physics from somebody Eric's version is
you know he went to Harvard and got a
PhD in mathematical physics so his
version is much better dressed than most
of the versions that I see okay and most
of the versions that I see are um you
know I find it disappointing because it
feels like people are you know writing
poetry that nobody's going to read and
they're doing it using kind of high
school level physics knowledge it's
mostly cranks people who may be
well-meaning but they don't realize that
they're way out of their depth yeah
right but the the main thing is that
they don't know what got done in the
20th century in physics and what got
done in the 20th century in physics
requires kind of graduate school level
knowledge to understand and we can say
it isn't true but it is true I mean it's
you know general relativity and Quantum
field Theory um you know Eric may say
they're simple theories I think they're
kind of simple theories but that's
because I learned about them when I was
I don't know 12 13 years old and by now
they seem like simple theories and if
it's simple to you or if it's even
marginally complex to Stephen what what
but also just the the the whole language
of of talking about things you know this
is kind of math graduate school type
language and that's now is there a way
to State these things about fiber
bundles and so on without sort of super
fancy language quite possibly maybe some
of the things we're trying to do will
give away to do that and it's part of
the hope of just bringing your
communities together let me move on just
because I we we don't have much time you
guys are very gracious with your time I
want to respect it and I have kids to
put the bed but I do want to ask the
following question that my audience is
asking when we think about uh the power
of these different approaches let's take
a step away from either one of yours
there's been a lot made about artificial
intelligence and the the prospects for
uh as Max tegmark has put it you know an
artificial physicist an artificial
Galileo what role do you guys see
artificial intelligence playing and then
you know where I'm going next I know
that you guys know I'm going to the
simulation hypothesis and I've talked to
you guys individually maybe offline
about this but my the audience is very
keen to know your two uh esteemed
gentlemen uh what you think about the
prospects for AI and as a benefit to
physics and then later we'll ask about
the simulation hypothesis let me start
with Stephen please I mean I've worked
on what is now called AI for about 40s
something years so I know a tiny bit
about it yes a lot of I don't know I
don't know where to start I mean if if
you're talking about machine learning if
you're talking about oh let's sort of
throw everything we know about physics
into a machine learning system and see
whether it can figure out the laws of
physics that's one level yeah that's one
level n Chomsky was on my show and said
you know he has uh he's sanguin about
what you just described perhaps uh as
his max teg mark But the true creative
stroke he has no you know the kind of
it's a little bit complicated because in
you know computational irreducibility
tells us that we can know the rules for
something but have no way to kind of
have a large scale narrative for how the
thing happens so in other words we might
say yes we've succeeded we found rules
that reproduce physics you say well tell
me how they work you say well here are
the rules but you say well tell me a
story about how they work tell me a high
level you know version of how they work
work that may not be possible I mean for
example in linguistics picking on on N
chomsky's area you know we may have a
description of how brains work and how
brains process language at a sort of
microscopic computational level and we
may still and it may be completely
accurate and we may still not have
anything we would call a satisfactory
science of
linguistics so in other words it's it's
a it's a slightly complicated thing and
the question of whether you know whether
we can get a current you know machine
Learning System to reverse engineer the
laws of physics you know to some extent
you can do that to a fantastic extent of
of figuring out everything you won't be
able to do that I don't think and and
you know the challenge again we we keep
on coming at things at really weird
angles but there's a you know okay the
way I see it there's kind of what's
possible in the computational universe
what simple programs can do there's this
kind of ocean of computational
possibility there's what we humans
understand that's another kind of um
piece and there's also what the physical
Universe does and you know I've spent a
large part of my life trying to bridge
between the sort of ocean of
computational possibility and what we
humans understand that's the whole sort
of point of the computational language
I've built is to have a way to have
humans be able to think about things
computationally um and be able to
communicate what they want to in in a
comput ational fashion now we have the
sort of third piece of physics and the
question is how we describe you know to
how we make this bridge between sort of
the physical Universe doing what it does
our ability to tell a narrative about
what's going on and this kind of
computation in the middle as this kind
of mediator of those two things but I
mean this is it's a mess I I would say
that there's a there's a a um I mean
this is a longer discussion and I think
this probably the wrong angle to come at
it with if you say are we going to have
a a you know a magic thing that we can
throw stuff into and and get out the
Theory of physics well I doubt it uh you
know you talked about the simulation
argument I might I always find it kind
of charming that people say you know I'm
an atheist I believe in science you know
what I believe is that you know there's
this we're in this universe and this
universe is actually a simulation
operated by operated
byond the universe
like but I'm an atheist exactly right
and then all the morality that entails
therein yes go ahead right but but I
think that the um more seriously I think
that that sort of argument is kind of
philosophically doomed Because by the
time you have definite laws for physics
there isn't much for the god to do so to
speak now the only thing you might say
is but the god gets to pick the laws of
physics ex except that we now seem to
have found that it actually doesn't
matter what the laws of physics are that
in some sense in this kind of again for
reasons again this is a slightly longer
story but what matters is that we are
observing physics in a certain way and
that's what gives us the laws that we
believe to be laws of physics and there
really isn't in a sense there's nothing
for the for the god to do other than to
decide that our universe is going to be
computational not hyper computational
not below computational and even if
those other sort of uh kind of
conceptual universes exist we you know
again it's it's a matter of science to
be able to say that we simply can't
communicate with them they're simply
they're just not things which are in any
way connected to what we can perceive so
I think it's it's a it's a um I do like
the idea though that there's a
connection between sort of AI physics
and the simulation argument I think
that's a that's a that's a that's an
interesting and bizarre connection which
which I think would be fun to unpack
some more and Eric you want to opine on
this or would did you yeah go ahead I
don't really know whether it even
requires Ai and or AGI there's a
particular kind of move that we haven't
programmed into computers yet so far as
I'm aware now Stephen probably knows
this much better than I do but there's a
weird move that comes up over and over
again which has to do with reaching for
something outside of your model and
knowing what to reach for so for example
you have a problem with the weak
interactions that a neut neutron when it
decays into a proton and an electron
called beta Decay doesn't seem to have
enough energy in the final products to
uh conserve energy from the initial
products so poy had to oh okay you're
explaining how neutrinos come to be yeah
okay fine yes right because it's it's
like one of the most important stories
we have not everybody knows it you have
a problem that you've got three lines
coming into a point and there's a
failure of conservation of momentum and
so you have to hypothesize a fourth line
you had a different problem when dck
came out with his theory which is that
he only had the electron and the proton
they were oppositely charged so he
decided that one was the anti-particle
of the other Instead This is the part
you know similar to the Peter Parker
Clark Kent issue he should have
hypothesized a positron to be the anti-
electon uh to be the anti-electron and
an anti-proton to be the anti- particle
of the familiar proton that move was too
much and in fact Heisenberg chastising
there's an issue about understanding how
spin comes about so effectively when
I've said that the square root is the
Psychedelic of mathematics you have to
give your computer program psychedelics
effectively so that it can invent new
stuff that is I can adjoin something
called I or i j and k to solve a problem
that was posed in the real numbers then
I get the querian or the complex numbers
or even the octonian I'm going to
augment my theory of something called
differential forms to something called
the theory of spinners can you discover
something called the fafan which is the
square root of the determinant for a
particular class of matrices can you
discover that the oiler class is in a
certain sense the square root of
something called the pontryagin class
all of these things are these
non-trivial moves where something that
is not present in the initial
formulation is guessable as the thing
that would be needed to complete the
stuff that we can see with stuff that we
can't to get a consistent system if you
can teach a computer about Primitives
and give it the ability to guess outside
of the system that you've taught it so
that it can self adjoin and I don't see
any impediment to this currently you
would have a system that would be potent
enough to explore not only the theory
that you feed it but the theory is that
it can build from that theory in in
essence the computer program is being
asked to do something similar than what
we're asking theoretical physics to do
again everybody complains about how
complicated this is and I'm sick and
tired and bored of hearing it Stephen's
correct you do have to learn some level
of uh mathematics typically this would
be somewhat like learning the French
language before exploring French
literature yeah it's a you know it's
expensive if you want to learn a foreign
language it costs money and time same
thing for learning differential geometry
and Quantum field Theory the situation
that we're facing is is that your
computer program has to be capable of
building larger Worlds by adjoining
things that would make puzzles in the
worlds that it knows about make sense
and that process of inferential guessing
outside of anything that's been taught
uh is a different problem than the
problem of finding let's say chess moves
or go moves by being able to search a
larger space where the search space is
implicit in the rules so do I believe
that it requires AGI now one of the
stories that I don't think we talk that
much about is how much we thought AGI or
artificial general intelligence would be
needed to do all of all sorts of things
and the great surprise is we don't need
anything like artificial general
intelligence to do most of the things
that supposedly intelligent systems now
do we thought that AGI and our
Consciousness and our intelligence was
necessary it turns out that much less is
usually necessary it is entirely
possible that we don't need to wait
around we can have the computers guess
it and to the issue of atheism and the
simulators and the simulated we have two
separate stories one story in which we
are going to build the intelligence the
AGI uh fear which is it's going to be
smarter than us we have another one in
which we are the simulated and there's
the simulat tour somewhere else if you
put the two stories together you see
that in a weird way God should be scared
about us becoming intelligent when we
finally learn what our source code is
this is the moment where Skynet becomes
self-aware and the thing that nobody
sees coming is that we are the AI we are
the AGI that emerged in somebody else's
system and whether or not that somebody
else was sentient or not is a different
question but Einstein asked this thing
he said I don't care about the Spectrum
or this or that element what really
bothers me is whether or not the Creator
had any choice or what interests me is
whether the Creator had any choice in
the way the world was made this is an
interesting concept of not being all
powerful but being all constrained and
perhaps the Creator's sole function if
you will is to turn on the lights and
everything else follows from that this
is sort of a li nitan monad construction
uh where the idea is that the rules
effectively all tell us what is going to
happen and there's very little room for
anything else but I think that part of
the reason we keep asking these
questions is to be blunt pessimism
rather than working on the actually hard
stuff either in Steven's case of trying
to do it through computation or my case
trying to remain within the standard
mathematical tool tiit people are so
frustrated that we waste our lives
talking about the mathematical Universe
hypothesis the simulation hypothesis we
we do all sorts of nonsensical work on
theories that have nothing to do with
physical reality and I just think it
would be better if we stopped wasting
our time talking around physics and
started talking about physics itself
well guys I have to go uh you guys have
been so generous with your time you've
answered a lot of questions that the
audience had and uh for that I'm very
thankful from both uh both uh s both
coasts any final words uh step I did
think there was gonna be one question
you wanted to ask us about uh peer
revieww and our attitudes towards it
which I think people are going to want
to know I think we we should wrap it up
maybe we'll take that up on a on a
future podcast with you guys
individually uh the time has really come
to go uh or I'll be in a lot of trouble
with a Multiverse of children screaming
at me uh Stephen anything you'd like to
leave the audience with any way that
they can engage and and perhaps
participate in the exciting work of
wolam research use wolam language use
wolam Alpha um you know you can come to
live streams we do frequently about the
physics project you can look at the
physics website you'll find all of the
um programs and things there seems like
people are finding this stuff so I'm I'm
which I which is which is great and
we'll put a link to the channel YouTube
channel where folks can find your many
and many live streams and presentations
as well Eric uh something uh for close
out where can people find you and engage
with you come find us at the portal I
think there's also an Eric Weinstein
Eric Weinstein org look for the
geometric Unity presentation which was a
special presentation within the portal
series I am looking forward to hosting
uh Stephen getting into the thick of his
theory and how how it works I think that
one of the things that people should get
engaged with is both why people are so
pessimistic and negative about every new
emergence you should learn about the
no-o theorems and all of the things that
a theory would have to fit I don't think
people are particularly negative I mean
honestly we've been playing up the
negativism but honestly what I'm seeing
is you know people being very
enthusiastic about what we're doing I
you know so far I I haven't seen anybody
you know I'd be interested to hear from
somebody credible who says I mean you've
said I don't believe your theory so
you're wait wait wait a second that they
no I believe that your theory is either
going to reproduce a lot of what it is
that we already know and then tell us
something new potentially I don't I'm
not disagreeing with it I've said that
it may be a face up to to some common
Summit it's certainly not the face that
I'm taking but I I don't think that's
character we should hash that out when
we do each other's podcasts the the
issue that I wanted to get to though is
yeah there is a lot of negativity you
can read about it in the Reddit comments
you can read about it very often left in
the YouTube comments some people in the
field are very disgruntled very few
people have wanted to say I've waited in
I've tried to look at it I've really
come to understand it and I still think
these guys are talking crap I think
Stephen's exactly right that the The
Coincidence of his work and my work
being on the same show I don't see any
need to fit them together and I think
that no but and I think that if they're
both right then they would have to be
fit together and most probably of course
they're both wrong because that we have
to say these words with that said get
excited about people who are trying to
find ways out of the Learned
helplessness that comes out of the no-o
theorems the pessimism that came out of
the LHC I I disagree with Stephen I
still think that there is a core
Community that's angry that people
outside are speaking to to the world
through this they may angry about you I
don't think they're very angry about me
at least not maybe they there is
pessimism I think Eric's talking
specifically think guarantee you there
are people angry about you too Stephen
it's not just about me it's in general
that we we're all up against the
question where nobody has any precedent
I think people one thing that I think is
the case is that what I've noticed for
example about peer review which we're
not going to talk about here in in
detail but you're sing it in it's the
people who say peer review is amazing we
need peer review are not people inside
science they're not people who actually
know it up close because up close it's
actually people in fact one thing's kind
of amusing we set up a kind of peer
review system for our project and to
date not a single person has submitted a
peer review not a single person it's
been several months
now how can people submit reviews of it
it just says there's just a link that
says peer review it's next to each one
of our documents I encourage I mean
honestly I I'm disappointed I thought at
least a few people would do it even if
even if they were like you know I didn't
really read this but it's all nonsense
anyway you know but what we actually
asked for more specifically which I
think is useful is somebody to say I
read section 3.7 and this you know and I
think it's correct or I think there's
this mistake in it or whatever else we
have had people like Sabine hassenfeld
are an eminent scientist and she's in a
video which is the first time you guys
appeared together where she criticizes
these theories and she's an eminent you
know fundamental theorist you know we've
been we've been in email correspondence
with her and and she asked a bunch of
questions which were very valid
questions so right engaging wait a
minute we gave her answers and she
disappeared so if she's still saying a
good does know what's going on there's a
problem well the fact is is that you've
answered her questions she had questions
that were reasonable and that's the
beginning of the process then if she
continues to say well he hasn't answered
my questions after he's answered the
questions and she hasn't responded then
we're in a different situation but I
know Sab Sab Saina can be kind of gruff
and and unpleasant but I know her to be
reasonably fair in in most circumstances
very good thank you guys uh you guys are
uh really spectacular it's it's so
generous of you to spend your time and
we got to see different sides of of your
ideas and try to reach some sense of uh
of you know different approaches that
are radically different and perhaps but
they have the same common goal which is
to really introduce the world to
Concepts that take us out of our
quotidian existence of politics Sports
and whatever the grandest concepts it's
why we should have talked about those
here that would have been more
interesting for me well let's let's do
more where we actually treat the people
who want to get into the into the meat
of it because I think that that's no no
I was saying Less meat because I don't
think this was so useful because I think
that I felt like um you know we we I
think we would have done better talking
about kind of the culture of Science and
so on I'm sorry I take all blame yes I
know I'm sorry it's my fault for not
getting to that thank you Stephen thank
you Eric love your work bye guys